it's great to welcome back to the
program today bill scher who is
contributing editor to Politico magazine
also host of the new books in politics
podcast part of the new books Network
and we're gonna play electability games
today bill which is exactly what what
I've been telling my audience I'm not
going to do to do I before we started
but as my audience will will know I've
been sort of evaluating Democratic
contenders for 2020 right now strictly
on issues and one of the reasons that my
audience likes this the people that do
not all of them is that they believe
playing electability games in 2016
led to Donald Trump being president now
you introduced in your latest article in
Politico which we're linking to the idea
that the problem isn't playing
electability games that electability
should be considered but that you've got
to make the calculation correctly is
that more or less the position you're
taking more or less I mean there's
there's no perfectly objective standard
here I think what constitutes
electability is going to be fluid from
election to election and you know
there's also the factor of what the
other party does you know what's the
matchup so you you might have someone
who has some electability strengths but
the other person has more or maybe both
candidates have the electability
problems and case of boy twice sixteen
and so one person is seen as worse than
the other and so things that you would
say in a vacuum like being an outright
bigoted might be and electability issue
in a lot of races wasn't a problem in
2016 but I do think you want to try to
maximize your electability to maximize
your chances of succeeding so if you say
you know what electability has taken us
down some bad paths in the past so
forget it completely let's just strictly
vote your hopes and dreams and let the
chips fall well I think there's gonna be
some risks going down that track too so
in 2016 was there a miscalculation made
about Hillary Clinton's electability
well we often electability has been
talked about
as strictly on some sort of ideological
spectrum so Bernie's too far the left
Hillary's more in the middle she's more
electable or you go back to 2004 Dean
he's too anti-war they just captured
Saddam Hussein in December 2003 being
anti-war is gonna be a problem come
election day John Kerry is a military
hero he's more electable I mean those
are very simplistic electability
calculations that in many ways certainly
didn't really hit the mark come November
so I would not look at it I've been
arguing that if you are on the left
therefore you can't win I think that's -
Pat so I broke it down to my political
piece into three electability tests what
is not only tell me what your strategy
is of winning but prove to me you can
execute it you know I'll go deep into
these after I lay them out and number
two is not just what positions do you
take but show me how well you defend
them it's easy to say I for XY and Z but
when rubber eights the road and the
criticisms come how do you defend your
position and number three there's always
something there's always some kind of
scandal kerfuffle gaffe and often people
will say well these these are ticky-tack
things you're being unfair but you
should let the media decide what's
serious and what's not well fairness is
doesn't doesn't count come election day
show me you know how to deal with it
prove to me that when you're in the
crucible you can get out I think those
the three main things I would suggest
people look for okay so let's I mean
let's pick some of those or at least
I'll provide some questions as to
whether these following items fall under
one of those three categories the
discussion around who can deal with
Trump's nicknames and insults and those
sort of bombastic attacks best is that
important to be thinking about now and
who can do that in your mind yeah I
would I didn't specify that this armored
car thing I mentioned that in a past
hour ago I think it's absolutely
and you could argue that sort of part of
what your strategy or part of how you
deal with scandals or quasi scandals but
it's all about if he's hitting you on a
weakness of some sort how do you deal
with it and Trump is his own unique X
Factor and we often Democrats in the
past have always had I think in their
calculation how do you deal with the
Republican attack machine how do you
deal with
Karl Rove how do you deal with Lee
Atwater though those kinds of things
obviously Trump his his own issue
because it's the candidate himself that
is the bully and what we saw in 2016 is
as as lowbrow as he goes he tends to
throw you off of your game he threw off
Jeb Bush he threw off Marco Rubio he
throw if Hillary Clinton you know you
you don't get to play your own game
because he ends up dictating the terms
of engagement so it's it's absolutely
important for a Democrat say to say what
are you gonna do about that are you
going to engage him better are you going
to fight him harder or fight him smarter
or are you gonna ignore him and say
that's II do bullies you don't give him
the oxygen I'm gonna stay focused on my
message and since he is already showed
he wants the metal in the primary now
presumably every candidate who gets into
the top tier or the frontrunner slot is
going to attract Trump attacks in the
primary so that's both opportunity and
and peril you get the show in real time
how are you gonna deal with it if you
don't do it well that might hurt you so
you and I have spoken before about which
issues are so-called voting issues and
which issues don't really seem to
influence one turnout into how people
vote and we've talked about social
issues we've talked about guns economic
policy you know very very long long list
here is there any particular issue or
topic right now that you believe is
being discussed but is not ultimately
going to impact electability so just
like some examples the Elizabeth Warren
DNA thing
Kamala Harris and her record as Attorney
General in California etc is there
anything right now you're seeing that's
getting a lot of talk but won't matter
well I can't say today that's not gonna
matter I might have thought in March
2015 the Hillary's emails were not going
to matter because did you see like what
one of the same-old same-old ticky-tack
things below mijo we were talking about
it in November 2016 it's a pen
whereas you might have thought we were
you're definitely to talk about Jeremiah
Wright by to that November 20 2008 but
Obama handled it so well at the moment
that if there was some lingering chatter
on the far right never became the issue
come election day for him
so that's that's her part of the
challenge so Elizabeth Warren she has
not had a great going back to I say
October so that is you know four months
dealing with the Native American issue
now every time she brings it up and make
some sort of it has to follow some sort
of apology and never seems to totally go
away no maybe the last one will be the
last one and it's not gonna come up
again but you know Trump loves talking
about Pocahontas and so it's hard to
imagine it well if she wasn't that many
that would completely go away and I
think she's yet to show that she knows
how to completely eradicate it from the
discussion I I don't want to say that
means she can't win there she should be
the nominee but I do think it is a
challenge for her how about any of these
other sort of more general talking
points that we hear like for example a
popular one on the left and Democrats
about electability is it shouldn't be
someone from the Northeast you need
somebody who is going to better appeal
to the Rust Belt and the Midwest and the
southeast and that's simply not going to
be someone from the northeast of the
United States is that at this point so
tired that that it shouldn't even be
discussed or is that relevant oh I think
it's very relevant I would put that in
my first test you know sure what is your
strategy and how are you gonna execute
it you know we and we have you know to
roughly competing theories of the case
amongst Democrats one is
that Democrats win where they can
galvanize the base juice the youth vote
juice the people of color vote and and
that way you win the turnout battle and
the other argument is that you have to
go after the swing and that's a lot of
white working-class or maybe it's
somewhat Midwestern or south west
suburban nights that are been
right-leaning
we don't love Trump and so if you're not
competing in the Midwest and some of
these other swinging areas and we have a
candidates not from there or doesn't
know how to appeal to those regions
you're gonna be in trouble
ah just so I'm not gonna tell you right
now I know which of those cases is
correct by I think the candidate if the
burden is on them to say what is your
theory of the case and show me how
you're going to meet your own standard
so take Amy Klobuchar for example or
sherrod Brown you know that part of
their arguments gonna be we're from the
Midwest we have to win here pick us well
that's fine but show me what you're
going to do now to win those areas Al
Gore's from Tennessee but he became a
different politician once he was compete
on the national stage he wasn't running
like he ran as Senator in Tennessee so
his past record wasn't relevant
Mitt Romney ran a different race for
governor of Massachusetts that he ran
for president so you didn't win
Massachusetts
tell me how is it that you won in those
areas maybe the way you won is not what
Democrat perverseness they want to hear
but show me that you mean it you can
explain it and how you're gonna execute
it because your past record is not
sufficient and same for the other
argument if you believe that juicing the
bass is the way to win
well juice it now show me how you're
gonna juice it show me who's showing up
to your rallies show me who are you
organizing show me that you have
unlikely independent voters who have not
voted in the past who are coming up on
stage you and saying yes I will be here
for you if it is this candidate you know
when Bernie ran in 2016 Hillary had
adduct ability issues I'm not disputing
that but when the voting started and the
turnouts in the primary were in
not as strong as 2008 and Bernie was
doing better in the low turnout caucuses
than it was in the primaries be the open
or closed that began in my opinion
undercut the message that he had some
special electability sauce that was
gonna carry the day so I think people
need to see the evidence not just the
assertion of what their strategy is okay
so for people who have heard us now talk
about all of these different
considerations for the last 12 minutes
and they say hey you know what guys half
the country doesn't vote any of these
candidates can win if they understand
the if the public understands the
importance of getting Donald Trump out
of office you can win merely on turnout
you shouldn't be talking in this level
of detail about electability how do you
refute that mathematically isn't that
accurate well sure but show me if you're
saying oh I'm the candidate who's gonna
get the non voters to show up show me
that one isn't it bigger than the
candidate you would hope at this point
if the Democratic voting public
recognizes that the differences between
Elizabeth Warren and Amy Klobuchar and
Kamala Harris are very relevant and
worthy of discussion right now but that
in the end the most important thing is
going to vote because turnout alone can
win this thing since half the country
doesn't vote then don't the specifics
become less relevant those reserves are
on the issues at the specifics of an
individual candidates electability well
I mean it's always the dream that you're
gonna change the turnout ratio that's
the complexion of the turnout in your
favor because there's always a
tantalizing vote parked on the sidelines
we never get to 100% turnout and so if
you can tilt that in one direction if
you can juice your turnout more the
other guy can juice his or hers you're
gonna win you know Obama definitely had
some turnout a benefit his side and
Donald Trump then had it eight years
later so I get the theory of the case
but it's it's not enough justice
I'm gonna do it because anybody can say
it give me the evidence so you can
actually do it and you have tests to run
to me and look crowd size isn't enough
you have a big crowd
that doesn't necessarily flecked what
the Bernie had big crowds in Brooklyn
for the New York primary and still lost
it by a considerable amount
so crowd sizes can be a deceiving metric
and so I'm not arguing to you that it's
easy to show the evidence or that
whatever it whatever evidence you can
show is going to be open and shut but
you got to do something if you're gonna
make the case that you have some unique
ability to win that others don't
alright bill scher contributing editor
to Politico magazine were linking to his
latest article we've been discussing
today bill pleasure is always having you
on wonderful it does well take care